Binary search trees are nice to look at when they're full but
there's no rule that states that BSTs need to look that way.
This is a completely legitimate BST,
but it looks very different.
There are two fewer children for every parent
and everything on the right is bigger than its parent.
We call this an unbalanced binary tree,
since the distribution of nodes is skewed to the right side.
A weird structure like this could start at the root,
but it could also take place in one of the sub trees.
You can also consider this to be the worst case scenario for a BST.
When the tree looks like this; search,
insert and delete all actually take linear time in the worst case.
Here the worst case would be searching through every element from the root to the leaf.
Thus the average case for these operations is Big O of log n,
and the worst case for all of them is Big O of n.